welcome to the Matt Walsh show everybody
thanks for being here thanks for
watching remember to subscribe on iTunes
to get the entire show or become a
premium member of the daily wire there
there I'll tell you right off the top
here that there will be a new law when I
am dictator of America I'm always you
know I have a running list of laws that
I'll be putting in place once I have
seized control if your Super Bowl
commercial is not funny
your company will be shut down and
everybody in your marketing department
will be sent to prison camps and or they
will face a $50 fine because I've had
enough I was watching last night there
were maybe two funny commercials the
entire time how is it that you've got
you're spending 50 trillion dollars on a
30-second ad literally and you've got
months to figure it out this is this is
when it comes to ads I mean this is this
is your moment this is the best you
could possibly do if you're if you're in
more if you're marketing or you're if
you're an advertising this is your
entire life has led up to this moment to
this 30-second spot between second
quarter and and halftime right now this
is it
how do you not come up with something
that's at least amusing I mean how do
you end up with something lame and
unfunny that's my question I'll have
more to say about Superbowl commercials
because of course it's very important
topic in a few minutes as for the game
itself I couldn't be happier that the
Patriots pulled off a victory and and
and and if you cannot appreciate the
greatness that we are witnessing from
the Patriots and Tom Brady then you sir
or ma'am are an American you are
anti-american and unamerican and I say
that I'm not even a Patriots fan
III I'm Ravens all the way so I'm not a
Patriots fan but the Patriots have
managed to be the best team in the
league for like two decades in a row
nine Super Bowl appearances six wins and
seventeen years the Steelers by
comparison okay they have six Super Bowl
wins they that goes back to 1975 they've
they've gotten those wins over the
course
of 40 years or more the Patriots have
gotten that number of wins and 17 years
that is impressive to say the least so
anyone who watches football knows how
hard it is especially these days in the
modern NFL to be a good football team
for two years in a row most teams
they'll have a good year then they have
a couple bad years and then they have a
good year and there's this there's this
kind of up-and-down peaks and valleys
this fluctuation that happens because of
the way the league is structured but the
Patriots are always good always they are
never not good every single year they're
good for two decades they've been good
they only missed the the playoffs I
think one time in the last 17 or 18
years
and that was a year that Brady was
injured and they still won 11 games and
they just happened to not make it which
is very rare for a team to win that many
games and not make the Super Bowl or not
make the playoffs so if you're a
football fan you have to appreciate this
because you're never gonna witness
anything like it ever again there's that
you're not going to ever witness this
sustained level of greatness no team
comes close to the Patriots there is no
team that even cook that is even in
their in their league basically they
should have it they should really have
their own league there's no other team
that gets close to them in terms of
sustained greatness and there's no
player in the history of professional
football that has gotten close to Tom
Brady and and the success that he's had
so ouput they're cheaters they cheat
yeah okay they had the Spygate thing 12
years ago or whatever what else they but
that was it maybe we should all move on
with our lives what else when people say
that what do you eat are you really
talking about the deflating the
footballs thing are you yeah they
they've been winning Super Bowls for 17
or 18 years because of slightly deflated
footballs yeah that's the reason right
that's it that's why they always make
the playoffs because of footballs being
slightly deflated let's let's the lead
just we'll just completely forget about
the fact that so many other NFL players
including Aaron Rodgers came out and
said yeah I do that all the time it's
totally normal everyone does it that's
that's it's not a big deal so we'll just
leave that aside we'll pretend that this
is all about footballs being slightly
deflated yeah I'm sure that you right
you could if you had a slightly deflated
football you can go out there and win
suit six Super Bowls right I mean that's
the secret come on
don't hate success it's on American
that's all I'm saying
alright let's talk about so we've talked
about success and greatness let's go to
the other end of that spectrum Ralph
Northam governor of Virginia last we
spoke about him on Friday morning he was
in hot water with only with
conservatives and and people on the
right not with the left or with the
media because he advocated infanticide
comments that by the way he never
retracted never apologized for it in
fact double down on and explained that
you know basically explain that hey I
mean the babies are deformed what else
are we gonna do with them I'm
paraphrasing but that was essentially
his message but as you know by now on
Friday night photos surfaced from
northerns medical school yearbook
showing his yearbook page and right next
to his photo in his yearbook page and
this got his medical school so he would
have been you know in his mid-20s right
extent is photo is a photo of two people
one in blackface the other in KKK robes
North Amisha Lee apologized and admitted
that it was him and said oh my gosh I'm
so sorry it was terrible it was racist
yada yada though he didn't stipulate
whether he was the guy in blackface or
the guy in the KKK robes which is kind
of an interesting side note of which
which is worse
neither are good but have we decided
which is you know on the scale of
badness which which is it is it worse to
be the guy in blackface or the guy in
the KKK robes as I as I said on Friday
if he was the guy in KKK robes he could
always just explain that he was that he
was you know was a Halloween party and
he was going as Margaret Sanger so and I
think that the left would actually
appreciate that but then he did a press
conference on over the weekend and he
retracted and said that actually he said
you know actually I want I that what
that wasn't me I wasn't that guy I you
know I thought that maybe I had been in
blackface at the thing or maybe I was in
KKK robes but but no it actually wasn't
me now that I had time to think about it
and his real is real excuse
that he got his he got his blackface
instances confused because no he didn't
wear black played blackface then but he
did wear blackface he admitted when he
dressed as Michael Jackson and darkened
his face with shoe polish which sounds
really unhealthy from a dermatological
perspective this was a talent show he
said and he danced as Michael Jackson
and so he thought that he should wear a
blackface if he's going to do that now a
reporter asked him if he's he's if he's
still able to dance like Michael Jackson
and specifically can he do the moonwalk
which is yet another important
penetrating question from a member of
our media because democracy dies in
darkness remember so we need guys in the
media to ask governor's if they could do
the moonwalk but it did lead to my may
this may be my favorite moment in the
history of American politics this moment
right here watch this we know we always
are asked when we're running you know
what kind of things should should our
people look into obviously there's
opposition research on the other side
but I will tell you know I didn't I
didn't ever really think about that
there would be anything offensive in my
EVMS yearbook but this this literally
hit me like a ton of bricks last night
it totally caught me off guard so it was
something that I wasn't expecting it and
to your point the people that do that
kind of research perhaps they should
have looked at that
yes that's right
[Music]
my wife says inappropriate circumstance
so he was really thinking he was really
thinking about you he was considering
doing the moonwalk right there on the
stage in the middle of a press
conference during the biggest PR crisis
of his career when his with his entire
career in life are on the verge of ruins
and he was thinking about doing him the
moonwalk right that in there and then
his wife had to step in and stop him
which which is which is really
disappointing I know we were we're all
thinking the same things like why we we
wish the wife wasn't there because it
would have been great to see really do
it but or attempt it anyway but he
needed his wife his wife was there to
say in appropriate circumstances that
the circumstances are not appropriate
for that now I have no respect for Ralph
Northam whatsoever I don't like him but
I can relate to that part at least that
part was relatable because as men we all
need our wives to tell us don't we when
when the circumstances are inappropriate
I rely on my wife for that kind of
advice on a daily basis you need your
wife there to say hey honey you
shouldn't moonwalk during a press
conference about the time when you wore
blackface don't that's not or you need
your wife say hey honey your
grandmother's funeral is not a good
place to organize an arm wrestling
tournament don't don't do that or or
whatever this is why we have wives so
that was relatable the rest was not over
all the press conference was a disaster
Northam Northam defense of know you've
got the wrong blackface photo I wasn't
blackface then I was blackface at a
different point that defense was one of
the worst defenses we've seen a
politician use in a very long time and
so Northam is now an embarrassment to
the Democrat Party so they're all
demanding that he stepped down and he
has very few defenders at this point
everyone's come out against him
they want him gone and they want his
lieutenant governor
Justin Fairfax to take his place his
lieutenant governor who happens to be a
black man is also younger you know I
think he's in his late 30s so it's it's
it and the other thing about about
Fairfax which maybe people don't realize
this is that Fairfax we used to be a
Planned Parenthood official or he worked
for Planned Parenthood in some capacity
so from the perspective of Democrats
you've got this this white guy who is
now there's the scandal because of
racist photos while his lieutenant
governor is black he's also more
radically pro-abortion even than Northam
is so as far as Democrats are concerned
yeah obviously get the other guy in we
got to get we got to get this we got to
get this old racist guy out and put
Fairfax in it is just so instructive
though to see how this is played out
if you think about it north um last week
came out and said that babies should be
delivered and then killed and that
provoked no outrage no criticism on the
left or in the liberal media none I mean
really none no but nobody no prominent
Democrat or anyone on the Left came out
to criticize this guy it was either
silence or agreement nobody was coming
out against him total silence then some
inappropriate costume 30 years ago
surface and that's what prompts everyone
to demand his resignation think about
where we are as a country as a people
when a guy can can announce that he's in
favor of executing infants and his
political career is in fine shape after
that but then some photo surfaced of a
naughty costume that he wore thirty
years ago in his mid-20s and that's the
thing that provokes all this outrage so
this is basically how it was this is how
the dialogue sort of went between
Northam and Democrats over the last week
or so Northam said let's kill babies in
a third trimester the Democrats it said
yeah yeah let's do that sounds good
matter of fact let's deliver babies and
leave them to die okay yeah sounds good
great or we could resuscitate them and
then kill them after that cool cool
sound sounds good let's we could do that
by the way I dressed as Michael Jackson
once dear god resign you monster this is
a disgrace it's it's probably worth
noting as I already did that Fairfax you
know more radically pro-abortion as I
said worked for work for Planned
Parenthood it really makes you think
doesn't it it makes you wonder where
these photos came from it's it's very
hard to believe it's impossible for me
to believe that nobody in the media
nobody in the in the Democrat Party knew
that there were photos from this guy's
yearbook with with some with somebody in
blackface and wearing a KKK costume
nobody thought to check that isn't that
exactly when when somebody is running
for a you know for an office like
governor they've got people on their
side who dig through their past to find
this sort of thing so that they can try
to get rid of it or prepare you know
figure out how they're gonna deal with
it when it comes out and going back to
look at old photographs
laughs and stuff here but that's exactly
the kind of thing that they look for
especially with thought with with
considering what happened with Cavanaugh
so you're telling me that nobody in the
Democrat Party knew about this and
nobody in the media knew about it and
then it just happens to come out only a
few days after it happens to come out
while Northam is is taking heat at least
from the right for the abortion comments
no III don't believe that at all my and
this is just a theory I have no way of
knowing that sure not but my theory
would be that the Democrats the the
Democrat Party and the media and of
course there's no distinction anymore
between those two groups they knew about
these photos they had them and that
somebody on that side of the fence
leaked these photos because Northam was
embarrassing the pro-abortion side and
he was embarrassing the pro-abortion
side by by exposing it by exposing it
for what it really is so no it's not
that that the Democrats were upset that
this guy supports infanticide know that
that's not upset by that at all they
agree with the mayor they're just upset
that he came out and said it and that he
is such a clumsy advocate for that
position they would much rather have a
guy like Fairfax to take that mantle in
that banter that mantle in that banner
there we go they'd much rather have
Fairfax do it so that would be my theory
I have no information to indicate that
at all but it's that seems to me to be
relatively likely because we always have
to remember on the left with the
Democrats it's always everything is
about abortion in the end that's what
everything is about everything comes
back to that for them it's always about
that said the same thing during
Cavanaugh all the heat that Cavanaugh
was taking this this the smear campaign
against him all of it all of these
people coming out of the woodwork it was
all
abortion because they saw him as a
threat to their so-called abortion
rights and I think Northam became in a
way a threat as well because he was
exposing that side and embarrassing it
and if you do that and if you're on the
left if you're a Democrat and you do
that and you make the pro-abortion side
look evil and insane you're not gonna
survive they're gonna get rid of you all
right
so the game last night was as I said a
little boring and that's when you rely
on the commercials to pick up the slack
and entertain you but that wasn't
happening and a halftime show with
maroon 5 that wasn't very entertaining
either that was no help though I do it I
did appreciate how you had yet maroon 5
and then you had Sponge Bob made an
appearance for some reason and then the
dude from Outkast showed up and Little
John was introducing them so all you
needed was like Norah Jones maybe or
maybe Good Charlotte to make an
appearance and then we could have really
been back in 2002 all over again
so that was kind of great but in the
commercials the commercials were not
only unfunny but also insufferable and
there was this running feminist theme
throughout all the commercials which is
good because the approximately zero
feminists who watched football must have
really appreciated all of the all of the
sucking up that the commercials were
doing to them so there were a lot of
commercials like this one here here's
one featuring Serena Williams
the world tells you to wait that waiting
is polite and good things will just come
but if I waited to be invited in I never
would have stood out if I waited for
change to happen I never would have made
a difference
so make the first move
don't wait to be told your place take it
don't wait for people to find you find
them
in work
[Music]
in love
in life
[Music]
and most of all
don't wait to be given power because
here's what they won't tell you we
already have it okay so there are a lot
of commercials like that just kind of
these vague platitudes female
empowerment all that kind of stuff and
that lead finally at the end it was kind
of it was all leading up to this moment
and this commercial aired towards the
end of the game when girls face their
challenges they're stronger when girls
work together they realize their value
when girls get to play they learn to win
okay so they literally ran a girl-power
ad I mean they actually had the girls
shouting girl power they ran a girl
power ad with little girls and football
pads during the Super Bowl insufferable
is the word I keep going back through
that because that's really what feminism
is now that's all it's become more than
anything it's just just just
insufferably just all you could do is
roll your eyes you just say stop already
we get it you don't need to you don't
need to shove this down our throats
every second and why do we need it
during football who is this who exactly
are you talking to who are you who are
you targeting and by the way are you
really and what you really want Gert
little girls playing football I thought
I thought the feminist is to say you
know don't we hear from the left all
time the football is dangerous you get
concussions I mean now we're telling
them to put on football pads and go play
football can you make up your mind but
if we're talking about insufferable ads
nothing could possibly be more
insufferable than what we saw from the
Washington Post The Washington Post now
as I said to to run an ad during the
Superbowl is not cheap I estimated fifty
trillion dollars maybe it's a little bit
less than that but it's certainly a lot
of money so you would think if you're
gonna run an ad there's there's a you
know the
ariza even with good reason behind it
you're trying to move product right but
the Washington Post decided to run an ad
during the Superbowl and the only reason
was just to kiss their own butts it was
just there just to pat themselves on the
back they decided to spend millions of
dollars running an ad to pat themselves
on the back and hope you have your
nausea medication ready because here's
the commercial when we go off to war
when we exercise our rights
[Music]
when we soar to our greatest Heights
[Music]
when we mourn and pray
when our neighbors are at risk
when our nation is threatened
there's someone to gather the facts
[Music]
to bring you the story
no matter the cost
[Music]
because knowing empowers us
knowing helps us decide
knowing keeps us free
now I just want to focus on one thing
there are a few things in that ad that
we people can that we could look at a
few ridiculous elements to it but
there's just one thing that jumped out
of me maybe maybe it jumped out as you
at you as well
there the narrator Tom Hanks said you
trying to show us all the sort of
moments and times when we need the media
there right we need the the truth
tellers in the media and he said when
our nation is threatened and what did
they show an image of to illustrate our
nation being threatened what are they
show well first of all let's think what
is what comes to mind for you from let's
say the last 30 years when you think of
our nation being threatened when you
think of a moment in a vent where our
nation really felt threatened where
everyone was you know where it felt like
we were under attack what comes
immediately to mind well we all know
September 11th so Washington Post was
running this ad trying to illustrate
when our nation is threatened we need
the media what do they show no they
don't show September 11th they show the
Oklahoma City bombing the if you think
that wasn't completely intentional then
I've got news for you there was that was
definitely a decision that was made
there was some real thought behind it it
wasn't that wasn't just you know they
were just grabbing for some random piece
of footage to put there to add to to go
with our nation being threatened no
that's a conscious decision no we're not
gonna show September 11th we're gonna
show Oklahoma City because Oklahoma City
was a white domestic terrorist attacking
us whereas September 11th well those
were Islamic radicals foreign Islamic
radicals attacking us so ironically as
the Washington Post is running this ad
to pat themselves on the back
congratulate themselves and try to try
to demonstrate how necessary they
and what great work they do instead they
Illustrated for us exactly the problem
with the media in our society it's
exactly that kind of thing it's it's
oftentimes it's kind it's kind of subtle
not very subtle I mean it's also pretty
obvious it's kind of subtle but there's
always that little bit of manipulation I
mean they they they inject propaganda
into everything they can never just be
straightforward
there's always it's always ideological
it's always political in everything they
do this is exactly the problem with the
Washington Post and with all these
left-wing mainstream media outlets it's
exactly that kind of thing even in this
even in that context they just can't
help themselves because they want us the
thing is that they want us when we think
about our nation being threatened when
we think about terrorism they want us to
associate that with right-wing white
Americans that's what they want that
Association to be not with not with
foreigners not with Muslims absolutely
pathetic alright I'm gonna get to a
couple of emails here don't have a lot
of time for it so I'll just read a few a
few of your emails if you want to send
an email to the show Matt Walsh show at
gmail.com this one is from Riley it says
Matt I've noticed that a lot of your
political opponents on Twitter like to
draw attention to your designation as a
theocratic fascist in your Twitter bio
critics will argue that theocratic
fascism has failed every time that it's
been tried but I say that wasn't real
theocratic fascism and if we just tried
it in our country we could finally get
it right I would love to hear you offer
further clarification and expand on your
thoughts for this theocratic fascist
regime that you envision with yourself
at the helm thanks yes I do if you go to
Twitter you'll find that I describe
myself in my bio as a theocratic fascist
and that is because someone sent me a
tweet a while ago and suggested
that I should describe myself that way
in my Twitter bio because in their mind
that's what I am and so I said okay and
so that's what I did now I think I know
what Riley is doing here
I suspect that Riley is not actually a
fan of theocratic fascism and he's
trying to embarrass me by getting me to
defend it and that's exactly what I'm
going to do because Riley you see I I
will answer your question even though I
suspect that was not sincere i I do
envision myself as the benevolent but
strict and just dictator of this country
that is my plan you know and what will I
do we'll all imprison all I will
imprison my opponents absolutely
I'll force everyone to adopt my belief
system I will squash any dissent with
violent force but but here's the thing
if you're listening to that plan and
you're thinking well that's that's not
really you know I don't know if I'm in
favor of that I just want you to know
that this will all be for your good I
promise I I I'm not I wouldn't do it for
my own sake and when I send all of my
political opponents off to prisons
that's gonna hurt me a lot more than it
hurts them it's not something that I'm
gonna want to do but I will do it for
your sake for your good and I just want
you to keep that in mind as you're being
frog-marched to the gulag all right this
is from Stevie says hi madam constantly
amazed how Democrats are increasingly
getting behind socialism if this is
truly their strategy don't they know
that business is and any person with a
sizeable income will move overseas or
use some form of tax evasion to escape
being robbed how would they continue to
fund their growing government without
those taxes seems to me that the plan
wouldn't last long I'm just shocked that
they wouldn't realize this if they just
thought logically for one minute is it
really just short-term greed and power
thereafter can you explain what their
logic is well if they thought logically
for one minute there's
problem Steve is that that's too much to
ask but really look this is you're
asking what is their strategy and of
course you say well they could just move
overseas or whatever obviously that's
what they would do if there if there was
a 70 or 80 percent tax on on on wealth
in this country which is what Alexandria
kzo Cortes wants obviously all the
wealthy people are just gonna move then
I got to stay here and pay that and
allow the government to bankrupt them so
they're all just gonna move of course
that's what's good what's going to
happen that is one among many other
problems with with that sort of plan but
yeah you talk about their strategy well
it's it's not about that it's not about
actually trying to come up with an
economic system that will work and that
will lead to prosperity or whatever
that's that's that's not what this is
about this is just about it's just about
for these politicians anyway now there
may be some ignorant rather stupid you
know Joe Schmo type liberals who really
do want a system like this and who think
that it would be a good idea but as for
the politicians who advocate for this
for them it's just class warfare it's
just stick I mean you've got Elizabeth
Warren out there psycho people did we
can't it's it's a it's immoral for
people to be wealthy we can't go look at
all these wealthy people living their
wealthy lives meanwhile she's got
millions of dollars so you think she's
actually opposed to wealth no but most
of these so-called socialist Democrats
and most of them are Bernie Sanders has
three houses so no he doesn't want to
give up his he likes wealthiest be fine
with it but it's just class warfare it's
just about manipulating their ignorant
supporters and followers it's just stick
is all it is now I'm not saying if they
were actually if they actually got into
power I'm not saying that they wouldn't
attempt to initiate some of these plans
I'm sure they would there
bass would demand it and also if they're
in charge of the government yeah they
would love to be able to take more money
and use it to advance their own their
own agenda
but my point is that you know trying to
outline all of the logical problems and
everything it it doesn't do anything
there's no point because that's not the
point for them the point for them is
just class warfare manipulation turning
people against each other to advance
their political agenda all right there
are a couple other interesting emails
there was someone has sent me an email
about wanting me to respond to people
who claimed that Jesus Christ never
existed at all as a person which is an
interesting email and you know what I
think I'm gonna save that one for
tomorrow because that's a longer that's
a longer response and so we'll get to
that and end plenty of other topics
tomorrow thanks for watching everybody
thanks for listening Godspeed